oh my gosh they told me it's not gonna
be delivered until 7
10. this is
an atrocity
thank you for the donation you guys are
so nice
i really appreciate the donations like
i'm really trying to save for this
computer
and i really want to buy like a nice
like good computer so the donations like
actually really help support the channel
because literally all my free money i
spend on either food
or literally equipment
lakers or suns tonight
um i don't care
my favorite color is turquoise i did
play basketball i was a center but i
don't like watching sports i never
coached
i i like to play i don't like to watch
it's not entertaining to me
you like how consistent i've been
putting out videos thank you i really
try
um i'm trying to at least keep up with
three a day
because i really want to make a career
out of this
how tall am i i'm six foot well just
thunder so like just under six
would you call kevin samuels
yeah i that'd be fun i'd be really
interested to have a conversation with
him
you like when i react to violent music
the problem is
i like
when i react to like music videos they
get demonetized every single time
so it's not very like motivating
if that makes sense to like
keep reacting to them if i don't get
paid
i mean obviously i know my audience
likes it but like it's
you know um i can they also like the
manosphere content too
was i ever called big bird no but i was
called big red with my hair
love so so was your funniest reaction of
all time
oh my gosh i should react to some more
but i just hate it because
half the time um
the videos really get like demonetized
and sometimes they are even blocked like
that's my problem so
i'll react to a whole video and then i
can't even post it
i just turned on live chat i don't know
what the difference is
but i guess i'm gonna find out mike
tyson was my
funniest reaction well it was funny but
he's like i'm a good father and
convicted rapist i'm like wait
what what
like how does that go together
my god damn
you said mike tyson never matured no he
talks like a 15 year old
hold up
guys what time is it 6 45 okay my
chipotle's supposed to be here at like
7.
i'm a semi-good husband oh okay okay
i didn't remember what he said
am i gonna share chipotle no
do not share food
647 so it's 703
it says he's gonna be here
i have a little bit of a lisp too if you
haven't noticed i don't do the s's right
i remember when he was on stage cursing
the dude out
i don't even sometimes these reactions
just like blend together like i've
listened so to so many can you be a
moderate i don't even know i could add
moderators
yeah you're my first moderator how
exciting
i'm hungry
god this chipotle is gonna slap
i said put your mom in a straight jacket
um let's see
no it says you're a moderator flash out
um when's the next collab with the
boyfriend
um i don't know maybe soon
i hope moderators even do i don't know
they time people out if it comes to that
or hide people they're basically
security oh the moderators
okay interesting
fun fact did you guys know i have nine
siblings which is kind of nuts
have i taken the big five personality
test
i think i have if you told me like
what the possible answers are i could
tell you
um like i i've taken a bunch of
different personality tests
but if you like said the answers what
they possibly could be i could
probably recognize what i got but not
like recall it off the top of my head
how many brothers five brothers five
sisters total
like well including me so like four
sisters for me
death grips what's that
oh okay no oh openness yeah okay so the
one jordan peterson talks about i've
taken that test
twice and i hated my results so much the
first time i took it again
and basically got the same thing um
so i'm pretty agreeable if they scaled
like on the one to ten i think i'm like
75-ish percent agreeable which i used to
hate
like i literally hated that about myself
that i was so agreeable
but it turns out people that are
agreeable like that's actually why
people like me
um like what i found i'm very open so i
was high in openness
um conscientiousness which
was what i was like the maddest about
because
it said i was low in conscientiousness
which
made me mad because i've always
considered myself like a hard worker
um however after thinking about it more
it also goes with like being very
detailed and organized which i'm not
um so whatever that was annoyed
um extroversion i'm like on the 90th
percentile of extroversion which makes
sense i'm a chatterbox
and i don't remember what it said about
neuroticism
um i like honestly don't remember
what neuroticism means and where i was
on that scale
the fact that you hate it is why it's so
accurate yeah i know um
i was so mad when i got that because
i've really always like considered
myself a hard worker
um and that thing just told me i was so
lazy
but i realized that like naturally i
don't think
i think i am lazy like naturally but i
still work hard
um
and
let's see neuroticism
and sensitivity to negative emotion i
don't remember
but i'm probably sensitive like i'm
i'm pretty emotional like i'm sensitive
um
but not that much for a girl so i don't
know
like i don't think a lot of people could
deal with the negative comments i deal
with
let's see
but i don't understand what these
have ever been incarcerated no
back to jordan peterson i absolutely
love
jordan peterson he is one of the people
that like changed my life
lazy people tend to work smarter and be
efficient with energy
i'm also very like i don't put it
disorganized which i think goes with
being
low on conscientiousness like i'm not
organized and i'm not
good at sticking to a schedule um
how tall am i i'm six foot ten pretty
tall
do i react to music yes i'm 24.
um
my food is gonna be here in like five
minutes i'm pumped
um
i don't think i can watch like the
videos you guys are putting in the chat
on here
conscientiousness is broken down to end
orderliness and industrious
i think i was um i think i was high in
industries and very low in orderliness
like super low
like because i'm very like
creative but i don't remember it's been
a while since i looked at my results
death grip song again send any songs you
guys want me to react to
send to my instagram which is just
pearly things with a z
um
trap gang yeah again send it to my
instagram
um that's the best way to get a hold of
me because
i always like accept the videos i want
to react to so i just have them in one
spot
oh my gosh the food is so close
uh maybe you can oh yes the food is here
you guys can come with me
oh i'm so excited
um do i also stream on twitch
i will but right now my computer isn't
allowing me
to stream because it's honestly just
so crappy of the computer like it's
too slow but twitch is coming soon
wait i gotta get my key
that's okay i think i know the code
do i have a sister i have four sisters
[Music]
so
[Music]
where is this food
let's see where this man is
because i'm starving
is this him uber eats
yeah chipotle right okay
thank you you too
can i introduce you to one of my sisters
maybe
am i two that are single
okay
oh my god i'm in very short chores but i
didn't care because i was just grabbing
food
that guy was giving me like a weird look
okay
sorry guys my phone goes in and out of
wi-fi
um my sisters that are single
are 19 and 17.
well i guess i am 13 but that's like
you guys shouldn't be hitting on my 13
year old sister obviously
um
do you have the same mother um
not everyone because some of my sisters
were adopted
so not everyone has the same mom and dad
but ever like the same two parents like
adopted everyone
this is way too much cheese
how did i survive with so many siblings
um
we all were in sports
um i love chipotle burritos but
the wrap is 300 calories so i don't get
it
i actually haven't been getting rice a
lot lately but i didn't eat a lot today
um no we can't adopt you guys
so
is
trust me if you stole my computer you'd
be giving it right back
because it just does not work
um i'm in la right now but
i'm from chicago if you're gonna have
any guests on your channel
um thomas sowell or jordan peterson
um
any videos you want me to react to
damn to me on instagram
so my goals are very simple
i got hot sauce white rice cheese and
chicken just
four things i used to get more but i've
kind of phased out like
all the unhealthy stuff i used to get
no you're right cheese is the last thing
i've like kept on but i've been thinking
about phasing that out too
and replacing it with like beans
the trees only on
hold up i'm gonna get some more water
oh i said i would've got you chipotle if
i knew you're gonna be back so
soon
you